Okay, so
you get to the end of the first lesson.
Here are the main takeaways.
First, build a wonderful,
amazing product that creates value,
charge money.
Try to charge the user who use it most.
>> Also, think about profitability
from the very beginning.
>> Have a strategy to identify
the challenges, and manage them.
>> Then stay agile for new challenges.
We can promise you, they'll come
in waves and will surprise you.
>> At this point,
you should have few thoughts about
ways to monetize your product.
>> But wait!
We'll go into detail on
the monetization models available for
different types of products
in the next lesson.
Please join us when you're ready.